in 2015
25 teams from around the world competed
to build robots for disaster response
that could perform a number of tasks
such as using a power tool working on
uneven terrain and driving a car the dog
sounds impressive and it is but look at
the body of the winning robot you bow
here you bow is trying to get out of a
car and keep in mind the video is sped
up three times you go from team Chi
start of Korea's a state-of-the-art
robot with impressive capabilities but
this body doesn't look all that
different from robots we've seen a few
decades ago if you look at the other
robots in the competition the movements
also still look well very robotic the
bodies are complex mechanical structures
using rigid materials such as metal and
traditional rigid electric motors they
certainly weren't designed to be
low-cost safe near people and adaptable
to unpredictable challenges we've made
good progress with the brains of robots
but their bodies are still primitive
this is my daughter Nadia
she's only five years old and she can
get out of the car way faster than you
oh she can also swing around on monkey
bars Reese's much better than any
current human-like robot could do in
contrast to you Bo the human body makes
extensive use of soft and deformable
materials such as muscle and skin we
need a new generation of robot bodies
that is inspired by the elegance
efficiency and by the soft materials of
the designs found in nature and indeed
this has become the key idea of a new
field of research called soft robotics
my research group and collaborators
around the world are using soft
components inspired by masculine skin to
build robots with agility and dexterity
that comes closer and closer to the
astonishing capabilities of the
organisms found in nature
I've always been particularly inspired
by biological muscle now that's not
surprising
I'm also Austrian and I know that I
sound a bit like Arnie the Terminator
biological muscle is a true masterpiece
of evolution it can heal after damage
and it's tightly integrated with sensory
neurons for feedback on motion and
environment it can contract fast enough
to power the high-speed wings of a
hummingbird it can grow strong enough to
move an elephant and it's adaptable
enough to be used in the extremely
versatile arms of an octopus an animal
that can squeeze its entire body through
tiny holes actuators are for robots what
muscles are for animals key components
of the body the naval movement and
interaction with the world so if we
could build soft actuators or artificial
muscles that are as versatile adaptable
and have the same performance as the
real thing
we could build almost any type of robot
for almost any type of use not
surprisingly people have tried for many
decades to replicate the astonishing
capabilities of muscle but it's been
really hard about 10 years ago when I
did my PhD back in Austria my colleagues
and I rediscovered what is likely one of
the very first publications on
artificial muscle published in 1880 on
the shape and volume changes of
dielectric bodies caused by electricity
published by German physicist William
Rankine most of you know him as the
discoverer of the x-rays following his
instructions we used a pair of needles
we connected it to a high voltage source
and replaced it near a transparent piece
of rubber that was pre stretched onto a
plastic frame when we switched on the
voltage the rubber deformed and just
like our biceps flexes our arm the
rubber flexed the plastic frame it looks
like magic the needles don't even touch
the rubber now having to such needles is
not a practical way of operating
artificial muscles but this amazing
experiment got me hooked on the topic I
wanted to create new ways to build
artificial muscles that would work well
for real-world applications for the next
years
I worked on a number of different
technologies that also promise but they
all had remaining challenges that are
hard to overcome in 2015 when I started
my own lab at cu-boulder I wanted to try
an entirely new idea I wanted to combine
the high speed and efficiency of
electrically driven actuators with the
versatility of soft fluidic actuators
therefore I thought maybe I can try
using really old science in a new way
the diagram you see here shows an effect
called Maxwell stress when you take two
metal plates and place them in a
container filled with soil and then
switch on a voltage the Maxwell stress
forces processor will up in between of
two plates and that's what you see here
so a key idea was can we use this effect
to push around oil contained in soft
stretchy structures and indeed this
worked surprisingly well quite honestly
much better than I expected
together with my outstanding team of
students we used this idea as a starting
point to develop a new technology called
hazel artificial muscles Hazel's are
gentle enough to pick up a raspberry
without damaging it they can expand and
contract like real muscle and they can
be operated faster than the real thing
they can also be scaled up to deliver
large forces here you see them lifting a
gallon filled with water they can be
used to drive a robotic arm and they can
even self send deposition Hazel's can be
used for very precise movement but they
can also deliver very fluidic must like
movement and bursts of power to shoot up
a ball into the air when submerged in
oil his latter facial muscles can be
made invisible
so how do hazel artificial muscles work
you might be surprised they are based on
very inexpensive easily available
materials you can even try and I
recommend that the main principle at
home take a few simpler bags and fill
them with olive oil try to push out air
bubbles as much as you can
now take a glass plate and place it on
one side of the bag and you press down
you see the back contract now the amount
of contraction is easy to control when
you take a small weight you get a small
contraction it's a medium weight you get
a medium contraction and with a large
weight you get a large contraction now
for Hazel's the only change is to
replace the force of your hand or the
weight with an electrical force hazel
stands for hydraulically amplified
self-healing electrostatic actuators
here you see a geometry called piano
Hayes lecturers one of many possible
designs again you take a flexible
polymer such as our zip lock bag you
fill it with an insulating liquid such
as olive oil and now instead of the
glass plate you place an electrical
conductor on one side of the pouch to
create something that looks more like a
muscle fiber we can connect a few
pouches together and attach a weight on
one side next we apply a voltage now the
electric field starts acting on the
liquid it displaces the liquid and it
forces the muscle to contract here you
see a completed piano Hayes lecturer and
heart expands and contracts when voltage
is applied viewed from the side you can
really see those pouches take in more
cylindrical shape such as we service the
ziplock bags we can also place a few
such muscle fibers next to each other to
create something that looks even more
like a muscle it also contracts and
expands in cross-section these hazel's
here are lifting away that's about 200
times heavier than their own weight here
you see one of our newest designs called
quads Donald hazel's and how they expand
and contract they can be operated
incredibly fast reaching superhuman
speeds
they even powerful enough to jump off
the ground
overall hazel show promise to become the
first technology that matches or exceeds
the performance of biological muscle
while being compatible with large-scale
manufacturing this is also a very young
technology we're just getting started
with many ideas how to drastically
improve performance using new materials
and new designs to reach a level of
performance beyond biological muscle and
also beyond traditional rigid electric
motors moving towards more complex
designs our Faisel for bio-inspired
robotics here you see our artificial
scorpion that can use its tail and prey
in this case a rubber balloon going back
to our initial inspiration the
versatility of octopus arms and elephant
trunks we're now able to build soft
continue make trailers that come close
and closer to the capabilities of the
real thing I'm most excited about the
practical applications of his latter
facial muscles they'll enable soft
robotic devices that can improve the
quality of life soft robotics will
enable a new generation of more lifelike
prosthetics for people who've lost parts
of their bodies here you see some
Hazel's in my lab early testing driving
a prosthetic finger one day we may even
merge our bodies with robotic parts I
know that sounds very scary at first but
when I think about my grandparents and
the way to become more dependent on
others to perform simple everyday tasks
such as using the restroom alone they
often feel like they're becoming a
burden this soft robotics will be able
to enhance and restore agility and
dexterity and thereby help all the
people maintain autonomy for longer
parts of their lives maybe we can call
it robotics for anti-aging or even a
next stage of human evolution unlike the
traditional rigid counterparts soft
lifelike robots will safely operate new
people and help us at home soft robotics
is a very young field we're just getting
started
I hope that many young people from many
different backgrounds join us on this
exciting journey and
help shape the future of robotics by
introducing new concepts inspired by
nature if we do this right we can
improve the quality of life for all of
us thank you
[Applause]